Our second look at what
does a patient is a look at.
Our more recent history,
the parts of it that have
medical consequences that
we will also trace in the
next couple of short lectures.
Here is a table of things that have
happened recently in human evolution.
Things that have happened since our
last common ancestor with chimpanzees.
We have a, an alteration in
the way that our brains grow.
We have prolonged postnatal brain
growth and delayed Myelin is Asian.
These are probably both associated
with our capacity for learning with our
heightened intelligence.
Uh,
and they appear to be
associated also with childhood,
which is a condition that
does not exist in chimpanzees.
Chimpanzees transition much more
directly from being infants into being
juveniles are brain size
has been much increased.
We have a descended larynx,
which is very probably associated
with our capacity for language.
We have a high density of eScreen sent
sweat glands that gives us enhanced
sweating capacity and we also have
increased ability to do endurance running.
So both of these are probably associated
with the ability to hunt down prey by
endurance running on the Savanna.
That also has to do with our hair loss.
So we are relatively naked of
hair compared to chimpanzees
in when a woman goes into labor,
when a human woman goes into labor,
she has earlier onset and a longer
duration of labor than does a chimpanzee.
Interestingly, we are able to cry, cry.
Crying is a social signal of distress
and it is not something that chimpanzees
can do, so it is an enhanced communication
ability. As part of our body language,
we have enhanced t cell function,
they are relatively hypersensitive,
so that gives us a enhanced immune
resistance and we have a thumb which is
longer and a little bit
more distantly placed.
We have larger muscles on our thumb and
that also has to do with our ability to
manipulate tools.
In addition,
our young are born relatively helpless
with more need for parental care for a
two year period.
We have a short inter birth interval
and the combination of those two traits
means that human reproduction is
necessarily social mothers need help,
otherwise they wouldn't be able to
pull off a short inter birth interval.
With a relatively helpless young.
We have delayed maturation,
so we start reproducing a bit later
than do chimpanzees and Bonobos,
we have menopause now.
If chimpanzees lived as long as we do,
we might observe
menopause in them as well,
but in fact our reproductive cycle
matches. There's pretty well,
it's just that they die just about at
the point when they stop reproducing and
we continue to survive and that has
to do with our enhanced longevity,
which is probably due to
our social defense and our
ability to avoid death from
predation.
Now,
what has been our recent history
of movement on the planet?
Homosapiens evolved from another Hammad
ancestor in Africa about 150 to a
hundred thousand years ago,
perhaps a little earlier and spread out
of Africa somewhere around a hundred
thousand years ago.
This thought that we paused in the
mid east for a while and it is likely,
as you'll see in a moment,
the first to move out of the mid
east went in the direction of Europe.
Others, however, probably fairly rapidly,
got down into US Australia
and a into New Guinea.
Then somewhere around
25 to 35,000 years ago,
East Asia was colonized
and about 12,000 years ago,
people made it across the Bering strait
and then spread rapidly all the way down
to the tip of South America
moving very quickly.
The colonization of the islands of
the Pacific is much more recent.
That probably came out
through Southeast Asia,
possibly Taiwan and went first to the
central Pacific and then from there to
Hawaii, Easter island in New
Zealand. Interestingly, by the way,
Madagascar also was only
recently colonized probably
about a thousand or 1200
years ago.
Okay.
Africa contains more genetic diversity
than the whole rest of the planet
combined.
As we migrated,
different groups encountered different
diseases and diets and the groups that
moved into America.
Pollen in Polynesia left some diseases
behind including measles, smallpox,
plague influence and typhus and having
been free of those diseases for on the
order of about 10,000 years when
they Rayanne countered them,
when Europeans then colonize those areas,
they experience very high mortality rates.
One recent result has been great genetic
variation in ability to resist disease
and to metabolize drugs. So if we look
at the global population of humans,
those are two very important
medical characteristics
that vary among individuals
and that are related
to this recent history.
Now we're going to take a look at what
we can learn from details of the human
genome,
and I would like to start by noting
that all humans are nearly identical.
Genetically.
Our genome is so large that both of
the following statements are true.
I am 99.9% identical to you.
That means we share 99.9% of our 3.3
billion nucleotides in our DNA sequence.
At the same time.
That old 0.1% means that my genome
differs from yours at up to 3.3 million
positions.
This is a consequence of thinking
about very large numbers,
so the first suggests how conservative
inheritance is and the second points to
the flexibility of inheritance.
Now note that all nucleotide
changes are not equivalent.
You can't really tell the difference
in the organism just from counting
nucleotide changes
because some are neutral,
some alter the structure of a
single protein and some change.
The control over large genetic networks.
So not all nucleotide changes are equal.
Genetic differences among human
individuals are of all these types.
So here is a picture of human
genetic diversity. This is
from a paper in science.
In 2008
a group headed by Lee at Stanford looked
at 928 unrelated individuals from 51
populations and they looked at 650,000
single nucleotide polymorphisms in each
individual.
So this picture that you see has 928
individuals or rate along the x axis and
the y axis is showing 650,000
single nucleotide polymorphisms.
The colors come from a program called
structure and structure is looking for
groups, groupings in the variation.
It can be set to different levels.
And in this case they found that the
best way to describe the data was to use
seven groups. And you see those seven
groups here, African, Middle East, Europe,
South Central Asia, East Asia, Oceania,
and America that can be tuned.
You can actually set structure
to look for other groups.
So the single nucleotide polymorphisms,
those are differences between two
strands of DNA at a single site.
And what you see reflected here are
those where one of the differences,
the rarer of the,
of the two differences is at
least 1% of the population.
Now using that same data,
they build a phylogenetic tree.
This is the tree and you can see here
that it's rooted down here where all of
the people in these groups are in Africa.
There's a very long branch here,
which indicates the migration out of
Africa at about a hundred thousand years
ago.
Uh,
this branch here moving into East
Asia and then over towards, uh,
North America.
Is that about 40,000 years.
These people here in the Middle East,
these people here or in Europe,
these people here are sort
of at the boundary between
Europe and Southeast Asia,
South West Asia.
And then these people are
in China, Japan, Korea,
Southeast Asia.
And then up here we have north
Americans and south Americans.
And here we have people in Melanesia.
Now
if you take that data,
you are able,
because there's so much data
to discriminate local groups.
So here for example, we can see
here are the Basques in this group.
Here are the French here, here are
the Italians, here are the Tuscans,
the Sardinians or off here.
The Russians are out here.
The Arcadians to people in the Orkney
islands are up here in the attic.
Gay Eds who are in the northwest
caucuses are down here.
So it looks like with this data you can
see quite a bit of differentiation of
what we would call ethnic groups, but
these are principle components. Okay,
so this is a statistical abstraction of
a huge dataset and I'd like you to note
how much of the variation
is being accounted for by
these principal components.
The first one accounts for 2.4% and the
second one accounts counts for 1.6% so
if you add that up and you look
at total human genetic diversity,
we're only looking at a pattern that's
being discriminated with 4% of total
human genetic diversity here.
If we then ask how is human genetic
diversity allocated between individuals,
among groups like the
ones we've just looked at,
among larger divisions such as people
coming from different continents and so
forth.
We find a very reliable pattern.
Most genetic differences are among
individuals and only about six to 11% of
those differences are among
what we call racist. Okay,
so here are the results of four
different studies of increasing technical
sophistication. This last one is
the one that we just looked at.
They used from three to seven groups
than they had populations and samples
within those groups.
So that would be a within populations
that would be variation among individuals.
In this last date of said it
was 89% among populations.
Then we can see that among all
of those groups that we saw,
the population groups in that slide,
this was 2.1% and some of the other
studies that goes up to about 8% so that's
like differences between the French
and the Russians and so forth.
And then when we look among groups, that's
somewhere between about six and 11%.
So these are the things that
people would call races.
The take home message on this is that
race is not a very significant biological
phenomenon.
And when we look at skin color,
which most people use is their
method of discriminating race,
we can make the following observations.
Our primate ancestors have light skin
under dark hair, so they're exposed.
Skin was light at birth and darkened
with age. If you take a champion,
you shave off all of its, uh, hair.
It has a fairly light skin color.
About two to 3 million years ago,
we evolved black skin to protect ourselves
against skin cancer and against fully
depletion when we lost our hair and we
probably lost our hair to improve our
ability to sweat the coolest down because
we had become long distance runners to
hunt down prey.
So when did we evolve other skin colors?
Well is probably between about 10 and a
hundred thousand years ago in some cases
fairly quickly.
And it was done to improve vitamin D
synthesis in cool climates where people
wore clothes.
Skin color is therefore
a superficial trait.
It's coated by a small number of
genes and it can evolve quickly.
It is caught in a trade off between the
benefits of Vitamin D and the costs of
skin cancer and fully depletion.
So to summarize,
we've evolved changes in many traits of
medical significance since our shared
ancestors with chimpanzees and Bonobos,
we emerge from Africa about 100,000
years ago. We are all Africans.
As we moved into environments
with different diets and diseases,
we've all genetic differences in disease
resistance and in drug metabolism.
Both of them are quite now quite variable.
Now among patients,
race isn't mostly a social construct,
it's not a biological reality,
but there are genetic differences
because the genome is so vast,
there are genetic differences associated
with ethnicity that do contain useful
medical information.
So we need a nuanced view of what we can
learn from the fact that someone comes
from Africa who comes from Europe.